a little scared come with me I don't
want to be alone okay you're cute uh-huh
and then people can see what the person
in here sees I see and you can fly like
a bird by flapping your wings and you
can tell those pedals so you can direct
this all here we go Oh transamerica baby
oh my god it started as a research
project we were founded by a third life
habitat in Zurich we were always
fascinated with flying so project at
Maxis and into drones and electron
flying stuff so it's fascinated with
flying and we're totally into kind of
this be our thing and that our
university was working in the
interaction design there we mostly bring
things about the embodiment so using
your full body or your body as an
interface between the technology or
machine and our body
something's happened huge explosion I
should probably run I feel you for not
doing anything that people around me
there are now over a million refugee
children food supplies are severely
strained and the number of refugees has
been brought exponentially
please help me escape this diverse
reality came
oh I'm seeing birds dropping thousands
and thousands of colorful ribbons on top
of me while I ascend into the Swiss Alps
or or or some sort of Fiore now I'm
moving through space I'm going to the
dark side of the moon all right I am
literally in a womb and there is a baby
looking at me a fetus literally just
more like this to me I see a white light
all right now there's some kind of
advertising because credit credits are
rolling credits are rolling credits are
rolling no matter where I go